Traductor: Alejandro Comas
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
A pesar de lo mucho que
hemos cambiado como sociedad,
la voz es, todavía hoy, el principal modo
de comunicación entre las personas.
Nuestra voz es una herramienta
muy versátil,
que nos permite transmitir
mucha información.
Y no solo a través del significado
de las palabras que decimos,
sino también en cómo las decimos:
el tono de voz, la intensidad,
la velocidad... nos permiten añadir
elementos de expresividad
al mensaje que estamos transmitiendo.
La voz es, además, un potente
instrumento musical
con el que expresarnos artísticamente.
La voz se genera cuando el aire
sale impulsado de los pulmones
y, al atravesar nuestra laringe,
hace vibrar las cuerdas vocales
que, en realidad, son los pliegues
que se abren y se cierran
a una velocidad que puede ir
de 60 a mil veces por segundo
en el caso de una soprano.
Durante la fonación, esta onda acústica
atraviesa nuestro tracto vocal que,
dependiendo de su forma y disposición,
la posición de la lengua,
la apertura de la boca.,
nos permite generar
los diferentes sonidos vocales.
Este sonido lo podemos capturar
mediante un micrófono y convertirlo
a una señal eléctrica o digital,
lo que nos permite luego
almacenarla, transformarla, visualizarla,
y luego reproducirla mediante un altavoz
convertida, otra vez, en sonido.
Pero, ¿qué pasa si queremos crear una voz
que no ha salido nunca de una boca humana?
Las voces artificiales no intentan imitar
la fisiología humana,
sino lo que intentan es conseguir crear
una señal lo más similar posible
a una grabación real, es decir,
no estamos imitando el aparato fonador,
sino lo que hacemos es intentar
reconstruir la onda acústica
que este aparato está produciendo.
Y la pregunta que podemos hacernos es:
¿tiene sentido expresarnos como humanos
a través de una voz artificial?
Junto a un equipo de investigadores,
llevamos años
trabajando el caso de la voz cantada,
intentando desarrollar tecnologías
que nos permitan generar
una voz artificial cantada
con todas las posibilidades
de expresión musical.
Os voy a poner un ejemplo donde,
a partir de una partitura,
podemos crear esta canción:
(Música)
Ahora os podéis imaginar
un compositor de ópera que está
componiendo su obra en su casa, y
pudiendo escuchar sus ideas musicales
cantadas por una soprano o
por la voz de un castrato virtual.
O nos podemos imaginar revivir la voz
de un actor famoso para generar diálogos
de una nueva película o, por qué no,
de un nuevo videojuego interactivo.
O tener vuestra propia voz artificial
que responda por vosotros
a llamadas telefónicas
o generar una voz artificial
que pueda doblar contenidos
en otros idiomas.
Para crear voces artificiales,
los métodos usados se basan
en lo que llamamos
"aprendizaje automático".
Estos métodos, lo que hacen es
analizar mucha cantidad de datos,
debidamente anotados, en nuestro caso,
nuestros datos son las grabaciones de voz
de una persona
y el texto que los acompaña.
Estos algoritmos lo que buscan es
identificar patrones
en las características acústicas
de estas señales, es decir,
en estas grabaciones.
Según si es una pregunta,
la entonación será de un modo terminando
la frase subiendo la entonación.
Esto son características acústicas
que estos métodos pueden aprender.
Además, como las grabaciones
y las características acústicas
en estas grabaciones provienen
de una persona en concreto,
podemos generar un voz artificial
de una persona concretamente.
Y, si queremos añadir emociones,
lo que necesitamos serán grabaciones
con distintas emociones,
con lo que podemos generar luego
distintas emociones artificiales.
Os voy a poner un ejemplo
de una locución normal
en modo neutro:
("For example, for the music industry,
this new paradigm can facilitate
the music interchange between countries").
Y ahora, la misma voz
un poco más enfadada:
("For example, for the music industry,
this new paradigm can facilitate
the music interchange
between countries!").
Entonces,...
(Aplauso)
...¿podemos crear una voz artificial
de cualquier persona?
Pues la respuesta es que sí,
si tenemos suficientes datos.
Es decir, en nuestro caso,
si tenemos suficientes grabaciones
de una persona, seremos capaces
de crear una voz artificial.
Actualmente, los métodos
que estamos utilizando
necesitan de una hora de grabación,
como mínimo, hasta las decenas
de horas, en el mejor de los casos,
si queremos conseguir una voz artificial
con la máxima expresividad.
Pero los investigadores
alrededor del mundo
están investigando sistemas con los que,
a partir de pocos minutos de grabación
de una persona, poder crear ya
una voz artificial.
Estos nuevos métodos lo que hacen es
agregar grabaciones de centenares
de personas distintas creando un mapa
de voces con gran detalle,
y luego, con pocos minutos de grabación
de una sola persona,
ya nos podemos aprovechar
de este mapa de voces con detalle
para crear una nueva voz artificial.
Nosotros hemos creado
distintas voces artificiales
con nuestro equipo.
Aquí tenéis el dibujo
de una cantante virtual, Mika,
con la que los usuarios pueden crear
nuevas canciones. O participamos también
en una campaña de publicidad donde
los fans de La Oreja de Van Gogh podían
componer letras que eran cantadas
encima de la música del grupo. Pero,
para ver las posibilidades expresivas
de una voz artificial, lo mejor es
que escuchéis un ejemplo de un experimento
que realizamos. Cogimos la voz
de tres oradores, que no son
especialmente buenos cantantes, y les
hicimos cantar una canción desde cero,
es decir, una canción que ellos
nunca grabaron.
(Aplauso)
Como hemos visto en este ejemplo,
las voces artificiales junto a los últimos
avances en inteligencia artificial,
nos pone encima de la mesa debates éticos
sobre la autenticidad y privacidad
en la sociedad del futuro.
La duda es si queremos superar
la reticencia a sintetizar algo tan íntimo
y personal como la voz, o realmente
nos aterra esa posibilidad de no saber
distinguir algo real de algo...
de lo que no es real.
Pero además,
también es muy importante aprovecharnos
de las posibilidades creativas,
de las nuevas tecnologías para crear
nuevas formas culturales, que, en realidad
es lo que hemos estado haciendo
desde los inicios de la humanidad.
Y, ya para terminar,
os dejo con una pregunta:
¿iríais a un concierto de un holograma
de David Bowie presentando su nuevo álbum,
creado con una voz artificial?
Nos vemos allí. Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)